but Chicago got to be said beautiful
women in this town I mean
none here but uh
I'm joking I'll go down on you but you
know
ladies you look great beautiful
definitely the better looking gender I
think we all agree on that like ladies
you guys are even sexy on accident like
you ever see a woman bend over or shoot
on her shirt for a second you're like
whoa
that's a great moment but do you ever
see a guy in short shorts something pops
out you're like ah call the police
it's a work of art
lingerie miniskirt feel like men we look
better the more covered up we are
business suit tuxedo man in uniform
that's why I think a Female Strip Club
should be a guy coming out naked and
slowly putting clothing on
you know some ladies like put on that
Blazer yeah by the engines like oh damn
he's an astronaut